So before proceeding with the candy bowl data, I wanted to take a moment and
describe the data that we collected in order to perform this analysis.
So if you recall, the goal is to understand what influences consumer choice.
In this case, the influencer's a candy selection, and so
we elected to record any attributes which we
thought might possibly have an impact on selection preference.
So, each record corresponded to someone selecting a candy.
For each record, the attributes that we thought to collect, which might have
an influence on candy preference were, name, gender, the type of candy.
We lumped color and flavor into one giant category.
Age of the person who's selecting, and ethnicity of the selector.
Now in addition to that attribute, in order to establish a baseline,
we also want to include a spurious attribute.
That way, any attribute that was ranked as having a weaker relationship than
that one, we know that we can safely ignore it.
So as our selection of a spurious attribute, we chose shirt color.
I think we can all agree that shirt color shouldn't have
an impact on what candy someone selects.
So, when we're evaluating the strength of relationships of any one of
these other attributes to candy choice, we know that if it
has a weaker relationship than that of shirt color, we can safely ignore it.
Now in addition, the records are chronological,
meaning that the records appear in the order in which selections were made.
Now that you know what all of the attributes mean, go grab ahold of
the data yourself so that you can follow along while we do the analysis.